was braucht man um jeden tag millionen
von paketen pünktlich abzuliefern
man braucht ein riesiges verteilzentrum
der ubs wird mord in world kentucky ist
eines der größten logistikzentren der
welt
bei der arbeit hier zählt jede sekunde
jede verzögerung kostet bares geld
die ps hat eine eigene airline die
tonnenweise fracht um die welt fliegt
mehr als 400.000 pakete werden hier jede
stunde bewegt ein logistik drehkreuz der
superlative
[Musik]
louis im us bundesstaat kentucky
seit 1982 ist die stadt umschlagplatz
für millionen von paketen tagein tagaus
der ubs world port ist in dieser zeit
mit seinen aufgaben gewachsen
an seinen 125 ladebox herrscht ständig
hochbetrieb
2,5 millionen tonnen fracht werden hier
jedes jahr bewegt tendenz steigend
es ist halb zwölf uhr vormittags wieder
pakete beginnen ihre reise in einem
zwischenlager wie hier in elisabeth 70
kilometer vom op s world port entfernt
viele unternehmen lagern ihre ware in
zentren wie diesem
hazel check ist gerade damit beschäftigt
den versand eines ganz besonderen
produkts vorzubereiten
sie will einen motorradtank ins 3000
kilometer entfernte seattle schicken
es handelt sich um ein ersatzteil der
englischen kult marke treu
zuerst kenne ich das etikett ab
alles klar dann gucke ich aufs etikett
auf dem steht wo ich hin muss
nämlich gang 300
[Musik]
für viele unternehmen ist es billiger
ihre waren bei logistikfirmen zu lagern
es hat eine ganze reihe solcher
zwischenlager in den usa das in der
satzung hat eine fläche von 100.000
quadratmetern
[Musik]
wenn das paket versiegelt hier eintrifft
öffnen wir es nicht
die logistik branche erlebt einen
weltweiten bogen
doch der kampf um die kunden führt zu
einem erbitterten wettbewerb unter den
branchenriesen
vor allem die großkunden sind umkämpft
sie bringt den unternehmen den meisten
umsatz
[Musik]
die zwischenlager sind dabei ein
wichtiges instrument zur kundenbindung
wenn die logistikfirma die produkte der
händler einlagert hat sie bessere
chancen auch den vertrag für die
lieferung zu bekommen
eine win-win-situation für beide sein
[Musik]
wie viel in den logistikzentren los ist
hängt maßgeblich davon ab ob gerade
ferienzeit ist oder nicht
je nach saison kann es da schon mal
stressig werden
in unserer abteilung herrscht gerade
hochbetrieb liegt wohl daran dass sommer
ist und alle ihre motorräder rausholen
der kunde ein viertel wird sich morgen
auf sein motorrad setzen
doch dem paket fehlt noch ein
entscheidendes detail
der strichcode
auf geht die reise
der strichcode ist wie ein
personalausweis des pakets
jedes einzelne produkt kann dadurch
immer und überall zweifelsfrei
identifiziert werden
[Musik]
um 1 uhr nachmittags verlässt der tank
das zwischenlager in lisse webborn und
wird von einem der insgesamt
21.000 you ps lkw-auflieger zum
logistikzentrum nach liebe transportiert
die stadt ist der perfekte standort für
das riesige logistikzentrum
[Applaus]
loewe ist mit 600.000 einwohnern nach us
maßstäben nicht allzu groß
[Musik]
und die lage der stadt ist ideal
global liegt mehr oder weniger im
zentrum der vereinigten staaten
von hier aus und fast alle ziele in dem
riesigen land innerhalb von maximal vier
flugstunden erreichbar
[Musik]
ein weiterer vorteil das
passagieraufkommen ist mit 3,4 millionen
reisenden pro jahr überschaubar
andere flughäfen wie zum beispiel
erlernte fertigen pro jahr mehr als 100
millionen passagiere ab
[Musik]
der ubs world port und der
internationale flughafen von teilen sich
ein 600 hektar großes gelände
auf dem passagierflughafen entfallen
dabei aber nur 20 games
der ubs frachtflughafen ist im vergleich
viermal so groß
entsprechend hat er ein großes
kontingent von abflug und lande slots
um viertel vor zwei kommt der
motorradtank im jupa es wird mord an
[Applaus]
der truck wird zu einem der entlade dogs
[Musik]
zwei arbeiter entladen den scheck von
hand und legen die pakete auf ein
förderband
sie sind zu zweit damit sie auch schwere
pakete aus dem laster herausbekommen
verschickt wird so ziemlich alles was
man sich vorstellen kann selbst frisches
obst oder fisch
danke
der motorradtank ist jetzt in der obhut
von samuel johnson und seinem team vom
operations planning control center kurz
egal ob das paket verspätet oder
beschädigt ist oder ob der strichcode
falsch ist johnsons leute kümmern sich
darum und zwar schnell
samuel johnson arbeitet schon seit über
20 jahren hier
er ist der mann der für einen
reibungslosen ablauf sorgt und eingreift
wenn es nötig ist
die opc abteilung sorgt dafür dass sie
alles fehlerfrei läuft dass jede noch so
kleine störung schnell behoben wird und
die ganze anlage gut funktioniert
das operation center kontrolliert und
koordiniert alle förderbänder im
logistikzentrum
denn jedes band das stillsteht kostet
wertvolle zeit
und der logistikbranche ist zeit geld
insgesamt 33
1245 förderbänder mit einer gesamtlänge
von 250 kilometern laufen durch den
world port
[Musik]
der ubs wird mord ist damit das größte
automatisierte paketzentrum der welt
[Musik]
der schlüssel zu einem reibungslosen
transport ablauf ist der strichcode
über 500 hoch moderne kameras kann lesen
den jeweiligen code aus und sorgen dafür
dass sie das paket auf dem richtigen
förderband unterwegs ist
und dass die paket container im genau
richtigen moment ihre fracht abkippen
bis zu 416 1000 pakete pro stunde werden
auf diese weise sortiert
[Musik]
der personaleingang ist auf der
südlichen seite des flughafengeländes
[Musik]
um zehn uhr abends beginnt tyler soll
seine schicht
[Musik]
nach seinem logistik studium hat er im
world port angeheuert und arbeitet hier
fünf nächte pro woche
für ihn beginnt der arbeitstag wenn die
meisten menschen ins bett gehen
ich bin gerade auf dem weg zum shuttle
bus der mich zu flügel bringt dort
bereite ich mich dann auf die schicht
vor und startete in die nacht
so will hat eine sechs stunden schicht
vor sich
er muss dafür sorgen dass die flugzeuge
so schnell wie möglich be und entladen
werden
nein
viel spielraum hat er dabei nicht vor
allem wenn es wie bei den meisten flügen
um expresssendungen geht
aber keine minute zu verschenken
[Musik]
der junge logistikexperte hat flügel br
recht was genau ihn heute nacht erwartet
weiß ja nicht nur soviel er wird wieder
eine menge güter und waren von a nach b
verfrachten und darf sich dabei keine
pannen oder verzögerungen erlauben
wenn ich hier nachts ankomme checke ich
erstmal meine e mails um zu gucken ob es
irgendwelche anmerkungen für die schicht
gibt
dann treffe ich mich mit meinen kollegen
und wir besprechen den plan für die
nacht worauf wir den fokus legen
anschließend sammeln wir unser zeugs
zusammen und fang mit der arbeit an dann
geht's los
teamwork und klare anweisungen sind das
a und o
tylers orgel koordiniert ein 20-köpfiges
team
heute nacht muss er zunächst fünf bis
sechs flugzeuge zum abflug klarmachen
das bedeutet insgesamt 500 tonnen fracht
die bewegt werden müssen
die männer haben pro flugzeug nur 45
minuten zeit zum entladen und neu
beladen
das an sich ist schon sportlich
und heute macht könnte ihnen außerdem
das wetter einen strich durch die
rechnung machen
heute wird ein bisschen mehr los als
sonst weil vatertag vor der tür steht
ich schaue mir gerade an wo die flüge
ankommen wir müssen die ankommenden
flüge im auge haben die die fracht
bringen die entladen wir und dann geht's
weiter zu den abflügen da wird die
fracht dann auf die flieger geladen die
rausgehen
ist die fracht entladen landen alle
pakete zunächst hier
es ist das herzstück die seele des us-
bonds genannt der korb
ein insgesamt 250 km langes förderband
system fährt die pakete durch die halle
alle förderbänder zusammen sind so lang
dass sie von hamburg nach berlin reichen
würden
pro sekunde werden in bergnot 118 pakete
verarbeitet
zu hochzeiten wie weihnachten könnte es
auch schon mal vier millionen pakete pro
tag sein alles muss so schnell und
reibungslos gehen die nur irgend möglich
[Musik]
das herz der logistik zentrale ist fast
200.000 quadratmeter groß das entspricht
20 fußballfeldern
[Musik]
auch der motorradtank dreht inzwischen
seine runden im system
[Musik]
jedes paket ist zwischen acht und 45
minuten auf den förderbändern unterwegs
je nachdem wie viele abzweigungen es
nehmen muss ist es im richtigen
container gelandet ist
um viertel vor elf kommt ein neuer
schwung pakete an tylers orgel macht
sich mit dem arbeitspensum für die nacht
vertraut
am stressigsten sind die abflüge um zwei
uhr morgens zwischen zwei und drei zu
der zeit ist das system ziemlich mit
fracht ausgelastet und drückt die ware
auf die bänder da müssen wir aufpassen
im moment gucke ich wann der nächste
flieger draußen am dock ankommt den
machen wir dann auf und fangen an die
container zu entladen
[Musik]
alles sieht nach einer ganz normalen
züchter aus routine
was opel noch nicht weiß es wartet noch
eine böse überraschung auf ihn und sein
team schlecht das wetter
[Musik]
um die wetterlage kümmert sich das
global operations center
von hier aus werden auch die
flugbewegungen aller us- maschinen rund
um den globus kontrolliert
[Musik]
es ist elf uhr abends
im konferenzraum des global operations
center trifft sich terroristen mit
seinen abteilungsleitern
richtung kümmert sich um schäden und
zwischenfälle aller art
jetzt will er wissen ob es probleme
während der tagschicht gab und dass es
irgendwelche warnungen für die
nachtschicht gibt
[Musik]
heute abend um 7 halb acht sah es so aus
als würden wir heute nacht eine
90-minütige schlechtwetterfront
abbekommen insgesamt waren mit zwei
stunden erhöhter wetter aktivität zu
rechnen was zu erheblichen
schwierigkeiten und verspätungen führen
könnte jetzt sieht alles schon wieder
etwas besser aus
terroristen hat permanent ein auge auf
die wettervorhersage denn er ist
derjenige der im zweifel wichtige
entscheidungen fällen muss
je früher er auf probleme reagieren kann
desto weniger stornierungen und
verspätungen gibt es
unserer flugzeuge wegen eines gewitters
in kansas city fest da haben wir eine
stunde verspätung und in milwaukee
könnte es nebel geben und auch in
hongkong shenzhen gibt es gewitter
das war's
die wettervorhersage sei nicht so gut
aus wir haben zwischen 5 und 6 uhr immer
noch ein gewisses risiko doch die gute
nachricht ist dass zu der zeit eine
menge flüge schon da sind oder gerade
reinkommen wenn die flieger unterwegs
zehn oder 15 minuten verlieren wird es
schwierig so eng getaktet ist das alles
wir müssen sehen wie es sich entwickelt
das gute ist auch wenn das wetter
turbulenzen gibt sollten wir in dieser
nacht keine unlösbaren probleme kriegen
[Musik]
das global operations center überwacht
die weltweiten fracht bewegungen aller
you ps flüge
das unternehmen fliegt allein in den usa
374 flughäfen an und 313 weitere rund um
den globus
zu stoßzeiten startet oder landet jede
minute ein flugzeug in lwiw
wenn es ein problem gibt muss das team
sofort reagieren
etwa flüge wegen schlechten wetters
umleiten abflüge neu terminieren oder
verspätungen in kauf nehmen um mehr
fracht in die maschine zu bekommen all
das entscheidet darüber ob ein paket
pünktlich ankommt oder nichts
[Musik]
viertel vor zwölf in der nacht
hurricanes aufgabe ist es die massen von
paketen pünktlich zu den kunden zu
bekommen
dieses netzwerk existiert um flüge zu
den lade dogs zu dirigieren und die
fracht zu den sortieranlagen zu bringen
am meisten spaß macht es wenn probleme
auftauchen die wir lösen können
dieses vergnügen hattrick dann heute
abend
sie hatten eine warnung auf ihrem
display aber das ist eigentlich normal
die verschwindet wieder wenn die
triebwerke gestartet werden ich schätze
dass die kuh eine 76 geflogen ist und
dass 75er display eine weile nicht
gesehen hat da gab es ein bisschen
verwirrung
das hatten wir vor kurzem schon mal
zum glück war es nur ein kleines
missverständnis
in den meisten fällen ist menschliches
versagen die ursache für verspätungen
[Musik]
doch dann klingelt wieder das telefon
terroristen bekommt einen anruf der ihn
gar nicht schmeckt
[Musik]
anfangs war die wettervorhersage der
meteorologen eigentlich ganz gut aber
jetzt haben wir eine
betriebsunterbrechung auferlegt bekommen
also seit sieben minuten nach 12 seitdem
können wir keine flugzeuge mehr entladen
keine pakete mehr
[Musik]
betriebsunterbrechung schlimmer kann es
kaum kommen
gps verlässt sich nicht auf externe
wetterdienste sondern hat im global
operations center seine eigene
wetterstation samt meteorologen sie
beobachten das wetter weltweit und
linken flügel bei bedarf um oder stellen
den betrieb komplett ein so wie jetzt in
lübeck
sicherheit geht vor
[Musik]
zehn nach zwölf
wegen des schlechten wetters machen
tyler sauber und sein team eine
zwangspause
niemand darf sich derzeit draußen
aufhalten um nicht vom blitz getroffen
zu werden
normalerweise würde jetzt hochbetrieb
herrschen im youth escort punkt
zu keiner zeit werden mehr pakete bewegt
sowohl draußen
als auch drin
der betriebsstart bedeutet verlorene
zeit die nicht mehr aufzuholen ist
für den größten logistikkonzern der welt
mit einem jahresumsatz von 66 milliarden
dollar geht es dabei um viel geld
während draußen der sturm tobt laufen
die förderbänder brennan weiter sie sind
nicht vom betriebsstopp betroffen
[Musik]
der motor tank ist noch gut in der zeit
seine nächste station ist zettel
20 41
obwohl es weiter störend ist der
betriebsstopp inzwischen aufgehoben
worden
auf der rollbahn countrysong will
endlich mit der arbeit beginnen es ist
sein erstes flugzeug heute abend eine
boeing 767
der frachtraum ist nur halb voll
vielleicht können so oppel und seine
männer ein bisschen zeit gutmachen
[Musik]
wir versuchen so schnell wie möglich zu
entladen um die fracht ins system zu
kriegen raus aus dem flugzeug rheine den
entlade bereich
eine hebebühne wird hoch zum frachtraum
gefahren sie muss zentimetergenau an der
tür andocken
[Musik]
doch die arbeiter haben einen fehler
gemacht
den müssen wir nochmal umparken um an
die tür zu kommen
[Musik]
der start in die nacht ist häufiger als
gedacht
doch beim zweiten versuch klappt soll
will bringt so schnell nichts aus der
ruhe normal ist sein job ohnehin nicht
ich habe mich daran gewöhnt auch an die
zeiten manchmal wenn ich im urlaub mein
rhythmus ändere ist es danach schwierig
sich wieder umzustellen aber eigentlich
macht mir das inzwischen nichts mehr aus
das team hin zehn minuten im zeitplan
hinterher
sowohl spornt seine leute an damit das
flugzeug rechtzeitig abheben kann
[Musik]
zuerst in container nummer acht genau
hierhin rechts links rechts links ok
egal ob eine halbvolle 767 oder ein
rappelvoll jumbo jet das prozedere ist
immer das gleiche
bei einem braucht man ein bisschen
länger als beim anderen aber der
ladeprozess ist der gleiche wie entladen
sie und dann bin laden wir sie wieder
immer eins nach dem anderen
das team beginnt mit der entladung
zum glück sind es nur zehn container
[Applaus]
es ist nicht ungewöhnlich dass die
flugzeuge nur halb voll sind denn die
lieferzeiten einzuhalten ist wichtiger
als den frachtraum absolut auszulasten
ein voller container wird bis zu sechs
tonnen
dennoch können zwei arbeiter in
problemlos bewegen
das liegt an den sogenannten kugel
matten die auf dem boden des frachtraums
installiert sind
die kugel matten bestehen aus stahl
dabei die keine große stahlkugel in
einem kugellager
sie lässt sich fast ohne widerstand in
alle richtungen bewegen
[Musik]
so können selbst schwere container ohne
viel kraft einsatz von a nach b
geschoben werden
ein ebenso einfaches wie geniales system
[Musik]
kugel matten wurden zuerst den
flugzeugbau eingesetzt
die ps hat die technologie übernommen
und den word damit ausgestattet von den
flugzeugen bis zu den entlade stationen
überall dort wo container bewegt werden
müssen
in einem flugzeug zählt jeder
quadratzentimeter
deshalb haben die container abgerundete
ecken die genau in den flugzeugrumpf
passen
[Musik]
halb zwei am morgen
terroristen hat ein weiteres problem ein
flugzeug das in kansas city ladung
aufnehmen soll um dann weiter nach liebe
zu fliegen hat ein technisches problem
jetzt gibt es zwei optionen
entweder wird der flieger beim stop over
in kerns repariert oder er fliegt direkt
nach läufer
in kansas city ist aber gerade
schlechtes wetter das weiter nach norden
zieht sie würden gerade so dran vorbei
fliegen aber es könnte knapp werden
wenn wir ohne verspätung rein fliegen
sollte es klappen doch wenn es
wetterbedingte verspätungen gibt wird es
dann war es das
am besten wäre es wenn das flugzeug
direkt nach lohr werde fliegen würde
dann würde zumindest ein teil der fracht
pünktlich ankommen doch dafür müsste das
flugzeug den sturm um fliegen und ob das
kerosin an bord ausreicht ist die frage
der kansas city fed macht mir sorgen
dann auf meinem bildschirm sehe ich dass
das schlechtes wetter ist
jetzt die frage gibt es eine bessere
option wie sieht mit dem kraftstoff aus
reicht der um einen bogen zu fliegen
rickens kollegen sind in ständigem
kontakt mit den piloten
denn nur die kann beurteilen ob das
kerosin für einen umweg ausreicht oder
nicht
und nur sie wissen wie gravierend der
technische defekt an der maschine
wirklich ist
[Musik]
der sturm zieht nur süden sieht so aus
als würden wir keine fracht bekommen das
wird heute nacht nichts gibt eine
auszeit allein wegen des kerosins muss
es landen
das flugzeug hat nicht mehr genug
treibstoff um ohne einen zwischenstopp
nachläufer zu fliegen
außerdem sollen sich mechaniker in
kansas city um das technische problem an
der maschine kümmern
erst wenn das behoben ist kann die
maschine weiter zum world port fliegen
kansas city anders geht's nicht das
müssen wir jetzt so akzeptieren
damit die pakete dennoch so schnell wie
möglich an kommen muss ein spezieller
notfallpläne aktivieren
am newport sind alle abteilungen
miteinander verbunden denn wie heute ein
flug verspätet oder gestrichen ist heißt
das dass weniger fracht ankommt als
ursprünglich geplant
das glaube operations center meldet
solche informationen und die daraus
resultierenden probleme dem operations
planning control center kurz
die mitarbeiter des opc geben diese
informationen etwa betriebs stopps oder
gestrichene flüge anschließend an die
verantwortlichen vorarbeiter an den
rampen weiter
die ersten die bei solchen problemen
informiert werden johnson johnson und
seine kollegen im opc
mutter natur hat uns blitz und donner
vorbeigeschickt aber die kollegen von
chelsea und dem ganzen team bemühen sich
um schadensbegrenzung
[Musik]
der motorrad an ist von alldem nicht
betroffen die boeing 747 die ihn
transportieren wird sollen einigen
stunden planmäßig eintreffen
zwei uhr morgens
tylers orgel und seine kollegen entladen
gerade ihr zweites flugzeug
das erste haben sie innerhalb von nur 30
minuten geschafft
dadurch haben sie die hälfte der zeit
wieder aufgeholt die sie durch den
betriebsstopp verloren hatten
[Applaus]
klar gibt es auch wettbewerb unter den
jungs aber das wichtigste ist die
sicherheit sie hat priorität wie können
wir es am sichersten machen direkt
danach geht es aber darum wer am
schnellsten ist das ist fast schon eine
art rivalität wir müssen immer
dranbleiben wenn das flugzeug rein kommt
müssen wir da sofort hochgehen und
anfangen jede verzögerung kostet geld
nachdem die container aus dem flugzeug
gezogen wurden kommen sie in die
haupthalle
hier im herzen des jupiters world port
werden sie auf einer der 200
parkpositionen abgestellt und dann
entladen
die arbeiter sortieren die ankommende
fracht
[Musik]
pakete auf die förderbänder
umschläge in säcke und dann auf andere
förderländer
generell gilt dass so wenig hände wie
möglich die pakete anfassen sollen
insgesamt nur an drei stationen
wenn die container epping und entladen
werden
und schließlich wenn sie mit dem
strichcode nach bogen auf das förderband
gelegt werden
[Musik]
seit jeher werden pakete und andere
sendungen von hand sortiert
die anfänge des post wesens gehen auf
das alte ägypten und babylonien zurück
im mittelalter richtete sich das porto
nach dem wert der sendung heute zahlt
man für größe und gewicht eines paketes
seit anfang der 80er jahre nutzt
yoopress den flughafen in nova doch erst
zur jahrtausendwende wurde er zum
größten fracht verteilzentrum der usa
seit 2002 ist er you ps word bord
seitdem bestimmen förderbänder das
geschehen auf dem gelände
durch die zunehmende automatisierung
wird die fracht heute erheblich
schneller verteilt als damals
[Musik]
viertel vor drei uhr morgens im jubi es
wird bord
der motorradtank dreht seine letzten
runden auf den förderbändern des
logistikzentrums
er ist eines von 2,9 millionen paketen
die ubs an diesem tag in den usa
bearbeitet
tylers opel muss sich darum kümmern dass
die frachtcontainer sauber beladen
werden zum beispiel mit dem motorrad an
dieser hat schon etliche kilometer auf
den förderbändern des frachtzentrums
zurückgelegt und hat noch eine 3000
kilometer lange flugreise bis nach
seattle vor sich
[Applaus]
manchmal ist es schon stressig gerade
nachts wenn das frachtaufkommen höher
ist als sonst oder wenn es umstellungen
in der sortierung gibt aber darauf sind
wir vorbereitet
wir haben hier spaß und auch gute leute
wir schaffen das auch wenn wir unter
druck stehen
das team hat die verlorene zeit fast
ganz wieder aufgeholt die meisten
flugzeuge heben planmäßig ab oder haben
nur minimale verspätung
in wenigen stunden wird auch der tank
seine reise im versiegelten container
fortsetzen
halb vier uhr morgens
terry jones schicht im general
operations center neigt sich dem ende zu
seine bilanz ist durchwachsen
ein halbstündiger betriebsstopp und ein
flugzeug das nicht wie geplant landen
konnte denn sein ziel ist dass alle
pakete pünktlich und wie geplant ihren
bestimmungsort erreichen
[Musik]
wenn wir die flugzeuge wetterbedingt
nicht rechtzeitig zum kunden kriegen
kann ich natürlich nicht ganz zufrieden
sein doch bis auf das halbstündige
wetter problem ist heute nacht alles
ganz okay gelaufen
von 0 hinaus werden täglich mehr als
1000 ps flüge auf der ganzen welt
koordiniert
eine einzelne flug stornierung ist da
ein ziemlich guter schnitt
die nachtschicht geht langsam zu ende
[Musik]
doch der motorradtank wartet noch immer
auf seine weiterreise
[Musik]
morgens um halb zehn
zwei stunden vor dem geplanten start
bereiten sich die piloten ellis atkins
und mike ashley auf ihren heutigen flug
vor in ihrer maschine werden sie neben
hunderten anderer pakete auch den
motorrad tag mit nach seattle nehmen die
beiden fliegen seit jahren zusammen und
sind ein eingespieltes team okay ich
mache den papierkram okay ich gucke mir
das wetter an
die piloten bekommen ihre arbeitspläne
schon wochen vor den flügen
falls trotzdem eine crew aus feld wartet
während jeder schicht eine zusätzliche
notfall crew im world port die sofort
einspringen kann
[Musik]
sieht alles gut aus heute
von westen her zieht eine wetterfront
auf aber unsere route verläuft weiter
nördlich und wie rumfliegen die front
hier das sollte kein problem sein wir
werden einen schönen flug abend
die beiden piloten machen einen letzten
check up
währenddessen weil er die außen crew das
flugzeug
auch der motorradtank kommt jetzt ein
bond
das flugzeug ist nicht irgendein
gechartertes flugzeug
die apps sitzt seit den frühen 80er
jahren eigene flugzeuge ein und pakete
von a nach b zu bringen
mehr als 20.000 angestellte kümmern sich
um den paketversand in 220 länder
[Musik]
mit einer flotte von 247 flugzeugen ist
jps die drittgrößte fluggesellschaft der
welt
jeden tag für das unternehmen über 2.000
flüge durch
mehr als 850 c nationen fliegt you ps
weltweit an
mehr als jeder andere airline
[Musik]
um die millionen von paketen zu
transportieren braucht die ubs viele und
auch große maschinen
die boeing 747 8f bietet platz sie kann
in ihrem 700 kubikmeter großen
frachtraum fast 140 tonnen
transportieren und es damit groß genug
um 50 suvs mitzunehmen
[Musik]
seit 2016 hat hugh ps 28 dieser über 300
millionen dollar teuren riesenmaschinen
gekauft
bis 2022 wird hugh ps mehr dieser
maschinen haben als irgendeine andere
airline auf der welt
auch der motorradtank verschwindet im
bauch von einem dieser fracht giganten
50 minuten später ist das beladen
beendet
was genau die piloten so alles
transportieren wissen sie normalerweise
nicht
[Musik]
wir wissen nicht wirklich was wir an
bord haben wenn wir gefahrgut mitnehmen
dann schon das ist vorschrift aber bei
sonstiger fracht manchmal sehen wir die
pakete in den containern und wissen dann
wo sie herkommen
wir behandeln die pakete wie unsere
passagiere
wir wollen dass sie genauso sicher
ankommen wie die fluggäste bei den
passagieren
früher hat hugh ps an wochenenden auch
passagiere befördert
doch als immer mehr low cost airlines
auf den markt drängten stellte you ps
das geschäft mit den charterflügen
wieder ein
seit 2001 konzentriert sich die airline
wieder voll aufs frachtgeschäfts
11 uhr vormittags noch 45 minuten bis
zum abflug
er ließ atkins und mike ainsley begeben
sich an ihren arbeitsplatz
vor dem abflug müssen sie ein striktes
prozedere einhalten denn routine schützt
nicht vor fehlern
schon gar nicht wenn jede minute zählt
bei apps ist der zeitdruck besonders
hoch denn wir garantieren eine lieferung
am nächsten tag
zwei stunden zu spät ist nicht gut wir
müssen pünktlich sein
wenn ein paket in new york city oder
sonst einer großen stadt zu spät landet
ist bereits viel verkehr auf der straße
und wir können nicht mehr pünktlich
ausliefern deswegen bei uns geht's um
zeigt jede minute zählt
wenige minuten vor dem start macht die
copiloten ellis apps noch einen letzten
außen check
[Musik]
kapitän michael macht der wahl einen
systemcheck im cockpit und gibt letzte
daten in den bordcomputer ein
das wetter kann immer ein problem sein
keine frage bevor wir losfliegen schauen
wir uns das wetter an und richten unsere
planung danach brauchen wir zusätzlichen
treibstoff eine ausweichroute um eine
schlechtwetterfront zu umfliegen wir
fliegen nie direkt in ein gewitter
reihen aber wenn es nur regnet ist das
okay das ist kein problem für das
flugzeug dieses hier kann sogar
selbstständig landen wenn die sicht am
boden sind schlecht ist lassen wir das
flugzeug automatisch landen das wetter
kann uns kaum aufhalten wir liefern
pakete und die müssen ankommen nicht
fliegen geht
die über 400 tonnen schwere maschine
verlässt ihre parkposition
dann gibt's / um die
startgeschwindigkeit von über 300
stundenkilometer zu erreichen
11 uhr 45
[Musik]
die hohen 747 mit planmäßig ab vor ihr
liegt ein vierstündiger flug an die
westküste nach sirte
zettel hatte yu ps eine besondere
bedeutung denn hier gründete john casey
1907 die american messenger company
nachdem er sich einen der dollar
startkapital von seinem besten freund
geliehen hatte
[Musik]
casey erkannte früh dass man für einen
effektiven kurierdienst große fahrzeuge
brauchte
[Musik]
anfangs wurden noch alle pakete einzeln
und zu fuß oder per fahrrad ausgeliefert
doch dann besorgte sich die firma eigene
zu stellen wagen
schon damals garantierte casey einer 24
stunden lieferung und schon damals
erhielten die fahrzeuge ihre typische
dunkelbraune lackierung die noch heute
ein markenzeichen von juki es ist
viertel nach fünf am nachmittag
der motorradtank ist auf dem weg zum
kunden natürlich in einem dunkelbraunen
kastenwagen
kurierfahrer richard williams liefert
das paket aus
durch den minuziös getakteten
auslieferungsplan ist der zeitdruck bei
den korea fahrern vergleichsweise gering
keinen zeitdruck habe ich bei der
auslieferung eigentlich nicht morgens
plane ich meine schicht bis zur
mittagspause dann schaue ich mir den
zeitplan für den rest des tages an so
dass kein zeitdruck entsteht
die auslieferung läuft immer gleich ab
überall auf der welt
des pakets gerne abliefern unterschrift
ein hort und auf zum nächsten
zu einem der insgesamt neun millionen
kunden roja
[Musik]
guten tag halte es für sie
keine unterschrift bitte
wie ist ihr nachname vielen dank schönen
tag auch danke
bei aller planung und aller routine
manchmal passiert doch etwas besonderes
ein auslieferung werde ich nie vergessen
eine kundin bad nicht die pakete in die
garage zu tragen damit ihre kinder nicht
mitkriegen was sie zu weihnachten
bekommen
[Musik]
auch wenn heute nicht weihnachten ist
ein motorradfahrer wird schon bald auf
seiner neuen triumph über den heimweg
nada und sich vielleicht ein bisschen
wie ein weihnachten fühlen
also was braucht man um millionen von
paketen tag für tag pünktlich
abzuliefern
ganz einfach eine der größten
flugzeugflotten der welt
ausgeklügelte systeme die tonnenweise
fracht reibungslos bewegen
hunderte von angestellten die die
kilometerlangen förderbänder beladen
jede menge maschinen und einen perfekten
plan
kurz
man braucht ein gigantisches
logistikdrehkreuz
eines wie den ju ps whirlpool im neubau